Speaker 1: I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on on this very powerful erection. Yes.
But Herschel Walker flank last night on Fox News
by Senator Lindsey Graham and Senator Ted Cruz
said that what's happening in Georgia,
this erection is about the people.
Speaker 4: Well, first of all, this election is
more than Herschel Walker does. We're excited
about the people.
Speaker 1:
Want to hear it one more time.
Speaker 4: Well, first of all,
this election is more than Herschel Walker
does. We're excited about the people.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Ted Cruz visibly moving his eyes
and then trying to play it cool. Well, listen, I
don't really have much else to say about this for
a guy who impregnated so many women and then urged
them to get abortions. This is quite the Freudian
slip. Vote Raphael Warnock on December 6th.